salut j'ai seulement 5 secondes pour
vous rappeler que la dernière de mon
spectacle solidarité après y'en as puis
c'est le 11 décembre au zénith de paris
de lire et dans la description nouvelle
vidéo salue aujourd'hui on va parler
belle de plein de choses on va parler
des insectes sociaux on va parler des
mammifères sociaux on va parler aussi de
l'intelligence animale du biomimétisme
et tout ça avec un auteur qui est
également un ami que j'ai reçu plein de
fois sur la chaîne il s'agit de bernard
werber en trente ans il a écrit 30
livres qui se sont vendus à plus de 30
millions d'exemplaires dans tous les
pays nombre d'entre nous l'ont découvert
en 91 avec son premier ouvrage sur les
fourmis et je trouve qu'elle a une
résonance avec son dernier livre qui
vient de sortir qui s'appelle la
prophétie des abeilles que je vous
recommande d'ailleurs regardez bien la
vidéo j'en ai à vous faire gagner cette
vidéo va se dérouler de la manière
suivante ura les discussions qu'on va
avoir entre bernard werber et mois
entrecoupées de face caméra où je vous
donnerai un petit peu des faits
insolites ou disent avoir
supplémentaires en rapport avec les
discussions que nous avons évidemment
précision d'avoir vidéo la prophétie des
abeilles est déjà disponible dans toutes
les librairies en ligne chez vos
libraires préférés bref je vous mettrais
un lien dans la description loïc qui est
de cette ruche et fabriquent nos du bon
génériques
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler de
l'intelligence animale le biomimétisme
on va parcourir ça avec ce que tu as
envie de dire toitures des populations
d'animaux d'insectes et puis toutes les
10 nations ont envie de faire mais peu
importe mais comme là je ne leur parlais
de la prophétie des abeilles parlons un
petit peu des abeilles pourquoi tu t'es
orientée vers les abeilles même si on
retrouvait déjà les abeilles dans
d'autres ouvrages qui faisait des
apparitions je voulais pas parler des
abeilles parce que mes petits chouchous
c'était les fourmis et puis j'ai
découvert le frelon asiatique et j'ai vu
des frelons asiatiques massacrer une
ruche et je me suis dit bon sens les
abeilles elles seront en danger et c'est
une gare barbares amp les seins alors le
frelon asiatique est avantagé parce
qu'il maîtrise le vol géostationnaire
donc il peut y avoir dix front aux ja
tic qui arrive dans une ruche ils se
mettent devant l'entrée et il tue toutes
les abeilles qui sortent et les couper
en morceaux et les abeilles ne savent
pas quoi faire donc tu as tu vas voir
différents société qui massacrent 50000
aux abeilles sans qu'aucune de trouver
la réponse donc mine de rien c'est les
méchants qui vont envie donner envie de
m'intéresser aux gentils parce qu'à ce
moment là dedans dans cette histoire il
est quand même des bourreaux et des
victimes et à partir de là je me suis
dit bon allez hop je vais m'intéresser
aux abeilles est en effet c'est
passionnant et du coup qu'un temps qu'on
est en train de parler des abeilles la
prophétie des abeilles comment tu le
pitch rey à quelqu'un qui se dit je sais
pas quoi lire demain
l'exercice de la rich il ya trois angles
le premier c'est que c'est l'histoire
d'un prof d'histoire qui fait des
régressions devient antérieures pour
savoir la réalité de ce qui s'est passé
au delà de ce cas dans les livres la
deuxième angle c'est l'histoire d'une
prophétie qui a démarré à l'époque
d'akhenaton et qui dit que les abeilles
y porte un message de solutions par
rapport à nos problèmes depuis la nuit
des temps et que cette prophétie nous
donne accès à la connaissance du futur
et la troisième c'est les templiers qui
sont
roman les principaux détenteurs de cette
prophétie et qu'ils vont tout faire pour
la préserver dans le détail je ne savais
pas que c'était à ce point complexe je
termine ma partie sur les abeilles du
coup sûr le côté sociétale est ce que tu
peux nous dire à peu près comment
fonctionne la société des abeilles et du
coup est ce que on peut s'inspirer des
loups est ce qu'on sait déjà inspiré
d'elle ou est-ce qu'il n'y avait rien à
faire d'abord il faut date et tout ça
les premières ruches
sauvages trouvés ça date de 120 millions
d'années donc on est vraiment une espèce
jeunes et les abeilles sont espèces
anciennes donc elles ont testé plein de
formules le petit souci pour pouvoir
copier à société abeil c'est que les
mâles sont évacués maintenant comment
fonctionne le système c'est que tout le
monde est motivé pour la réussite
globale de la ruche de la rue donc il
n'ya pas d'ego mounir c'est comme s'ils
se brancher sur l'esprit de la ruche
quelque part il se pose plus de
questions existentielles et ils sont
toujours heureux de voir que le système
marche mais c'est un système aussi où
les communications fonctionnent de
plusieurs manières la première manière
c'est la danse donc une exploratrice qui
a découvert une source de pollen va se
mettre à faire des huit dans lequel elle
indique la position c'est pas pour cela
il ya le soleil le nombre de tours va
donner la distance et va donner la
quantité après elle revient dans la cité
esma tapoter avec l'abdomen et ça fait
un tam tam dans toute la rue ce qui
signale qu'il faut aller chercher le
pollen après il ya d'autres notre
communication qui se passe par le miel
lui-même par le goût du miel hockey dans
le goût du miel il y a le nombre
d'enfants qui doit naître donc c'est un
ensemble qui fonctionne avec une
information globale permanente et des
gens motivés ou sociétés humaines
fonctionner qu'une communication qui
marche pas si bien que ça même si on est
très fiers notre internet et de notre
télévision et de tous les réseaux en
fait on se comprend pas bien et on est
pas tous orientés en mai direction donc
on perd beaucoup de temps et surtout on
gaspille beaucoup d'énergie on explique
beaucoup de matières aussi pour un
résultat qui est pas terrien il ya aussi
une autre chose de formidable dans la
société
des abeilles c'est que elles sont en
permanence elles produisent le nombre
d'enfants qui vont pouvoir être nourri
le syli a plus de matières premières
elle sera de faire des enfants
c'est-à-dire sont tout le temps
autorégulé l'un des drames de la société
humaine c'est qu'on fait des enfants par
tradition par culture ou par peur de ne
pas revoir de retraite quelqu'un en inde
ou en chine s est notre planète ne peut
plus fournir suffisamment de matière
première pour nourrir une aussi grande
quantité d'humains donc on ne sait pas
s'auto réguler donc mis des choses qu
entreprend che et société insectes c'est
sensé à l'organisme complet harmonie
avec la nature et puis il y avoir cette
idée aussi que si on détruit le milieu
au final les prochaines générations vont
être vendus plus avoir de sources ni
pour se nourrir ni pour construire des
cités de toujours bon à savoir numéro 1
est ce que vous saviez que les abeilles
ont deux estomac à dans leur estomac
pour digérer et elles ont un deuxième
estomac qu'on appelle le jabot ou
l'estomac amiel qui sert à stocker le
nectar des fleurs pour le ramener à la
ruche et fabriquer du miel ensuite il
sert aussi à stocker de l'eau toujours
très important dans la fabrication du
miel en gros ça leur sert de petites
poches de transport le jabot le deuxième
estomac les fourmis aussi en noir mais
là c'est différent c'est un jabot
sociale qui leur sert à stocker de la
nourriture qu'elle où elles vont pouvoir
piocher dedans en fait plus tard c'est
une rupture qui va pas s'altérer comme
ça mais on dit que c'est un jabot
sociale parce qu'elles peuvent aussi
régurgiter de cette estomac les formes
pour le transférer à une de leurs
congénères c'est fou nous on n'a qu'un
seul estomac et ça va que dans un sens
des fois ça rend compte mais c'est pas
le même propos et pour compléter ce que
disait bernard werber il ya même vingt
cinq mille espèces d'abeilles dans le
monde c'est énorme si on compare ça par
exemple dix mille espèces d'oiseaux ou
aux quelques 5000 grosso modo espèces de
mammifères c'est vraiment très très
présent les abeilles et il faut que ça
dure les abeilles ont fourni à l'homme
le premier goût sucré c'est à dire
cesser les premiers dessert l'homme
préhistorique il vous fait tout le temps
de la viande sanguinolente et jesús
aller dans la bouche et là tout d'un
coup avec les abeilles il a des couilles
la douceur et après ce qui a été
découvert c'est que le miel est un
médicament on a une plaie ouverte si on
met du miel dessus
désinfecte mais ça aide aussi à bien
digérer et c'est de l'énergie énergie
pure si on doit combattre si on doit
fuir en intérêt à voir du miel est ce
que vous saviez que lors de l'excavation
d'un site à tbilissi en géorgie on a
retrouvé du miel en gros ce sont des
pots de miel intacte qui ont cinq mille
ans avec du miel parfaitement
comestibles à l'intérieur on a également
retrouvé du miel datant de plus de 2000
ans dans des tombeaux égyptiens
parfaitement comestibles aussi encore du
savoir fabien oui bien sûr avec plaisir
les abeilles mellifères elle visite
environ 2 millions de fleurs il fonde en
quatre-vingt mille kilomètres pour
produire en quantité de miel 450 grammes
ces abeilles font environ deux fois le
tour de la terre pour produire seulement
450 g de miel quand je disais que le
miel c'était quelque chose de précieux
d'ailleurs tout le monde sait que les
abeilles elles vont collecter du nectar
du pollen mais peu de personnes savent
aussi qu'elles collectent du miellat le
miellat donc ses produits par les
insectes qui sucent la sève des plantes
et c'est pour ça que parfois vous pouvez
être étonné de voir une plante qui est
infestée de pucerons et beaucoup
d'abeilles autour c'est qu'en fait les
abeilles elles vont aller titiller les
pucerons pour récupérer le miellat le
stockage et le ramener à la ruche
d'ailleurs en arrivant à la ruche les
abeilles font une danse devant la ruche
pour communiquer avec les autres c'est
de ça dont on parlait avec bernard
werber tout à l'heure en fait leur danse
elle va permettre de donner l'indication
de l'endroit où se situe cette bonne
source et de nectar ou de nourriture ce
point intéressant est la danse va donner
une position par rapport à la ruche et
au soleil ce sont de vrais me gps tiens
je bascule maintenant sur sur les
fourmis qui sont
au-delà des marques de fabrique et
contre colt et maintenant qu'on le dit
bernard werber on pense vite à fourmies
quand même pour les fourmis je crois on
a fait beaucoup de biomimétisme elles
ont inventé beaucoup de choses au final
vincent inventé la guerre sont inventé
l'agriculture elles ont inventé les
solariums ils ont inventé 2 nourry
saison inventé le fait de manger des
champignons il ya phare il ya beaucoup
de choses qui ont dû être inspiré jeu
pour ajoute quelques petits points de
détail intéressant à savoir est ce que
vous savez que 10 % de la biomasse de la
terre c'est-à-dire 10% de la masse
biologique résidant au dessus de la
terre est bien 10% de cette biomasse ce
sont les fourmis c'est le poids de
toutes les fourmis cumulé il ya encore
10 % c'est le poids des termites étudia
ouais il y en a quand même pas mal
certaines espèces de fourmis sont
complètement asexué c'est à dire qu'il
n'y a pas de système de reproduction
classique avec l'envol des princes et
des princesses qui vont s'occuper en
fait de faire la génération future si on
prend l'exemple par exemple d'une
colonie de fourmis amazonienne très
spécifiques
en fait elles se reproduisent par
clonage elle même et donc quel clown
génétiquement en fait elle se tourne
elle même et elle fabrique que des
filles ce qui donne des sociétés
d'innombrables fourmis incroyable où il
n'y a pas à celle mal de dents on a
parlé des abeilles en a parlé aussi des
formes ou quelles autres espèces on
pourrait citer qui vivent en tant que
société parallèle à l'humanité dans les
insectes il ya des termes ils
construisent qu'on est en afrique en
semblant sur le pays détermine ses
considérants citadelle et les sociétés
terminé existait avant les abeilles et
avant les fourmis donc scellé les
premiers à avoir mis au point la vie
communautaire et avoir créé des villes
le fait que des animaux se soient mis en
groupe c'est un phénomène qui a pris du
temps série à un moment il ya un accès
dit attends on va être plus fort à deux
puis à 3 puis à 10 et au final ils se
retrouvent quelques milliers à
fonctionner ensemble mais en même temps
le système du groupe fonctionne je
parlais dans choisi un mode de pandore
du des crapauds donc les crapauds
migrants en général du nord vers le sud
mais l'arrivée des autoroutes a fait que
des crapauds quand il arrive dans une
autoroute en fait font tous écrasés et
donc il ya toute une communauté de
crapaud qui meurt juste parce qu'on a
créé une autoroute entre sur le chemin
ancestrale qui le prenaient est une
adaptation qui a été fait sur les
crapauds c'est que maintenant quand on
décide de migrer quelque part est une
toute petite minorité qui ne prend pas
le chemin ancestrale mais qui prend le
chemin qui est beaucoup plus long et en
fait ceux qui vont prendre je mens et
strahl où tous mourir et il n'y a que
ceux qui ont plus le chemin long qui ne
va pas directement en chemin au but qui
va qui vont arriver à survivre donc nos
sociétés ont intérêt à faire que quels
que soient les choix globaux et une
petite minorité qui fasse autre chose au
cas où ça marche mais permettez moi de
vous rajoutez quelques infos qui sont en
rapport on va dire connecte avec ce
qu'on vient de dire mais qui sont
toujours intéressants à savoir tout à
l'heure on a parlé des abeilles
présentent depuis énormément de temps
sur cette terre est ce que vous saviez
que les libellules également sont
présentes depuis 300 millions d'années
sur terre peut-être un nouveau livre
pour bernard werber non je parle des
libellules mais il ya également les
sauterelles les sauterelles étaient
présentes avant l'arrivée des dinosaures
en fait les insectes sont fascinants si
vous prenez l'exemple du papillon
facteur rouge il développe son propre
poison en faisant quoi en mangeant des
plantes toxiques et il arrive à
transformer cette toxicité sans la subir
pour devenir lui-même empoisonnés ils
sont trop forts la taille quelle
profession des abeilles mais c'est vrai
qu'on connaissait tout le travail sur
les formes y est dans tout le travail
que tu as fait sur les formules sur les
abeilles on entendait parler des
terminaux milieu et aussi des rats ils
ont des comportements que je reconnais
beaucoup plus je vais chez les humains
nairas que d'autres espèces animales que
soit mammifères aux insectes sont
intéressants
puisqu'on parle des sociétés c'est
vraiment un sujet trop petit sortir
plein d'idées il y en a une c'est qu'on
a le choix entre la société les fourmis
aux sociétés des reins donc la société
des rares j'ai commencé par les reins
est une société on est démis
systématiquement les faibles donc c'est
une société dure qui fonctionne à la
manière de darwin cécité pas costaud tu
dégages donc
et dans une société de rats les rats se
bat pour définir les rapports de
hiérarchie les rats ont des chefs ils
ont des barons ils ont ils maltraitent
les femelles donc c'est une société ça
corresponde société guerrière dur il n'y
a pas de pitié il n'ya pas d'empathie on
abandonne les vieux les malades et il
est ce qu ont été blessés et on se dit
on s'en fout on veut que les meilleurs
en bas et c'est le contraire la société
fourmis dans lequel une société fourmis
si durant une bataille il ya des soldats
qui ont perdu des membres ou qui ont été
blessés ils vont tous être secourus et
ramenés dans la même zone où ils vont
être soignés donc société fournie
fonctionne en mode on est de tout le
monde et il n'y a pas de faibles il ya
juste une cohésion du groupe mais comme
il n'ya pas d'individualisme du coup il
peut pas y avoir de faibles good for
passe de société la c2 forme de
collectivisme quelque part dans la
société rallye d ensemble on va gagner
mais vire ont tous les faibles et dans
la société fourmies c'est ensemble on va
gagner mais on peut on plus aidé les
faibles voilà c'est la nuance si on
regarde les sociétés humaines on a pas
moins des aspects rat
trompette quant à spir a et des aspects
fourmis normalement l'aspect fournit sa
devrai aspect social ça devrait te les
socialistes puisqu'ils sont pour la
société qui devrait qui devrait
représenter ce choix politique et de
l'autre côté il ya le choix
fascistes ou
certains aspects du capitalisme dans
lesquels il ya une compétition il ya des
barons qui apparaît ce qu'est un minot
le capitalisme et rats voilà vf que
c'est pas la même violence mais si ce
n'est que dans la réalité ce qui s'est
passé c'est que d'abord le communisme si
on prend le cas par exemple du
stalinisme ou le système soviétique a
reproduit un système encore plus dur le
système capitaliste et le système
capitaliste aménager des zones sociale
les médecins sans frontières le fait pas
la croix rouge tous les systèmes d' aide
aux blessés aux pauvres et où sont
apparus dans la société européenne
moderne capitaliste donc c'est pas si
simple mais il faut repérer j'allais
dire dans les discours politiques au
delà de l'étiquette
lesquels sont plutôt rares lesquels sont
plutôt fourmi du coup on met les
abeilles plus vers opus vers les
formules oui c'est vraiment un système
similaire merci beaucoup bernard merci à
toi lui aujourd'hui bravo pour ce
nouveau livre je vous dis comment le
gagner dans quelques secondes celui ci
parce que j'en ai à faire gagner pas le
mien le mien je le garde je te dis
encore une fois à remercier bernard
werber pour son temps et ses discussions
qui sont toujours passionnantes vous
avez déjà pu le voir dans d'anciennes
vidéos à moi notamment dans la vidéo sur
l'échec ou la vidéo sur la passion on
apprend à chaque fois pas mal de choses
à son contact et c'est très stimulant je
vous recommande vivement son nouveau
livre la prophétie des abeilles qui est
sorti déjà il ya un bon mois qui est
disponible en ligne et dans toutes les
librairies et sept exemplaires la
bernard la signer oui je l'appelle
bernard et je vous le fais gagner je
vous fait gagner aujourd'hui sur mon
instagram @ fabien olicard et vous
pouvez participer pour gagner cet
exemplaire mais cet exemplaire précieux
parce qu'il est dédicacé par bernard
werber dans la description vous trouvez
ça et vous trouvez encore une fois
également le lien pour vous procurer le
nouveau livre de bernard werber je mets
un lien aussi bercé réseaux sociaux si
vous voulez le suivre et puis je veux
aussi vous mettre un lien vers les
éditions albin michel depuis 30 ans et
avec cet éditeur que bernard werber
travail donc comme ça vous aurez tout
l'intégralité de l'offre de bernard
werber si vous voulez le découvrir vous
recommande la prophétie des abeilles et
puis d'autres livres dont on parle
parfois moins comme le papillon des
étoiles j'avais fait une vidéo là dessus
en 2016 en tout cas j'espère que cette
discussion entre nous vous a autant
passionné que moi elle m'a passionné
parce que je disais ce qu'il disait lui
évidemment n'oubliez pas que la fin de
mon spectacle approche il reste plus
qu'une poignée de dates après c'est
terminé je l'art est dans la grande
dernière le 11 décembre au zénith de
paris je crois qu'il reste encore
quelques places le lien pareil dans la
description prenez soin de vous très
bientôt ciao